[Musique]
Jean-Bernard Caron et son équipe mettent
la main au dernier préparatif
il s'apprête à passer un mois en
montagne à la recherche de trésor cachés
dans les schistes de burgères après deux
ans de préparation l'expédition prend
enfin son envol
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à 2500 mètres d'altitude
dans un lieu qui doit demeurer anonyme
parce que les fossiles se vendent à prix
d'or sur le marché noir
le campement inicit dans un rare secteur
plat ceinturé d'une clôture électrique
pour se protéger des animaux sauvages
le groupe de chercheurs internationaux
est animé par la même passion découvrir
de nouveaux fossiles de nouvelles
espèces toutes ces montagnes que l'on
voit aujourd'hui dans les autour de nous
ça représentait en fait il y a plus de
500 millions d'années et les fonds
marins
[Musique]
une riche fond animal étrange et très
diversifiée peuple le fond marin à
l'époque cambrienne
que vraiment il y a eu une explosion de
la vie et du coup ça fait beaucoup rien
que nous pour rien que nous pour
comprendre un peu comment les groupes
ont évolué
les fossés l'extrait de leur armure de
roche sont intactes
les animaux ont été ensevelis rapidement
par des coulis debout et n'ont donc pas
eu le temps de se décomposer ou être la
proie de prédateur
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'on a trouvé des
accumulations incroyables de poissons
donc il nous montre qu'il vient en clan
peut-être pour éviter les prédateurs
les travail étaient ingrats piocher à
flanc de montagne dans dépêche couche de
roche mais combien satisfaisant c'est
sale mais c'est le meilleur étape c'est
l'étape la plus
excitant parce que on sait pas ce qu'on
va trouver en fait
à sa première expédition comme
assistante recherche en 2012 Quand
l'important gisement du canyon Marba a
été découvert c'est un travail de l'oeil
chaque fossile est unique et c'est
comprendre les fossiles les analyser
c'est vraiment
ça passe par l'expérience d'analyser
toutes ces variations de fossiles en
fossiles de comprendre l'unicité de
chaque spécimens
par Canada propose trois randonnées
guidées ailleurs dans les Rocheuses pour
permettre aux visiteurs d'observer et
manipuler les fossiles mais pas question
d'en garder un souvenirs
[Musique]
en novembre 2020 des gardes parc et la
police de Longueuil ont saisi 45
fossiles dans une résidence privée
[Musique]
l'amende la plus importante à avoir été
infligée jusqu'à présent pour le retrait
illégal de fossiles des schiste argileux
de burgès les premières cages journée de
cette expédition était merveilleuse on a
fait beaucoup de très grandes
découvertes scientifiques le
paléontologue rapporte de sa septième
grande expédition dans les Rocheuses
canadiennes des milliers de spécimens
certains encore jamais décrits par les
scientifiques ils seront lavés
catalogués consolidés et mis dans des
collections au Canada et ailleurs
en tout 2000 tonnes de pierres ont été
expédiées au Musée royal de l'Ontario
ici Julie Carpentier Radio-Canada au
parc national koutenais